Virtualization has made
the lives of software developers
much easier by streamlining
the process to deploy software.
So what's virtualization anyway?
Virtual machines, also known as virtual
servers, are full-fledged computers with
CPU, memory, and storage, but it's all
virtual or simulated, not physical.
They have operating systems,
files, and applications.
They don't necessarily live inside
a physical server on a one-to-one ratio.
In fact, several virtual machines can
live within a single physical server.
To the outside world, there's really no
difference between a physical server and
a virtual server.
They both can serve up websites,
host applications, and contain data.
You can spin up a virtual
machine on a desktop PC,
on a server, or in the cloud.
Why would you want to
use virtual machines?
Let's look at a few use cases.
Say you want to set up
a testing environment that is
a mirror image of production.
Virtual machines will allow you
to do this quickly and securely.
You can also run single purpose virtual
machines to support a database,
authentication services,
or log aggregation.
You can use virtual machines to
create high availability clusters and
minimize downtime.
By using virtual machines, you can
allow for the redundancy and failover
that was previously possible only with
the purchase of additional hardware.
And there are many other possible
applications, these are just a few.
Now let's look at the similarities and
differences between servers and
virtual machines.
Both servers and virtual machines run
operating systems and applications,
serve up websites and respond to pings,
and they can be networked.
In contrast to servers,
virtual machines don't have
a one-to-one relationship to hardware.
You can run several virtual machines
on a single piece of equipment.
They allow you to add hard drive
space or memory much more easily.
You don't have to buy a new
server when you run out of space.
They boot faster and are easier to move.
They require more processing power and
memory.
This is especially true for
hosted virtual machines.
They're easier to troubleshoot, and
they have different requirements for
security.